lawyers negotiate deals and manage
lawsuits involving billions of dollars
each year to do that they need more than
purely legal expertise
if you don't know numbers and you can't
deal with concepts like economic loss
and likelihood of income in the future
you'll find yourself sort of at sea
without a compass
you need a fundamental understanding of
finance
how to read financial statements how to
analyze them and how to use financial
concepts to value a business or a patent
or a marital estate
you need more than law to help a client
even decide whether to sue
lawyers cannot leave accounting finance
and valuation
to a finance team or outside experts
through examples of valuation disputes
and presentations from real world
practitioners this course will teach you
how to interpret
and use financial data
make a business case for a deal or a
lawsuit
and know when and how
experts can support or undermine
your work
based on an essential course at harvard
law school this course is one of the few
available at the intersection of law and
finance a lot of lawyers are not real
strong in numbers so if you can do both
i think you have an advantage over some
of your colleagues
walk in the footsteps of experts to
learn how they use judgment to answer
difficult questions from both a
financial and a legal perspective
[Music]